Typically, the virtual address space of a process
running on a processor, let's say your desktop, your
PC, your laptop, and so on, is much
larger than the physical memory that is allocated for
a particular process. So the role of the
virtual memory manager in the operating system is to
give the illusion to the process that all of
its virtual address space is contained in physical memory.
But, in fact, only a portion of the virtual
address space is really in the physical memory. And that's
called the working set of the process. And the
virtual memory manager supports this illusion for the process by
paging in and out from the disk the pages
that are being accessed by a process at any particular
point of time so that the process is happy
in terns of having its working set contained in the
physical memory. Now when a node, a desktop,
is connected on a local area network to
other peer nodes that are also on the
same local area network it is conceivable that
at any point of time, the memory pressure,
meaning the amount of memory that is required
to keep all the processes running on this
node happy, may be different from the memory pressure
on another nodes. In other words this particular node
may have a much higher memory pressure because the work
load on this load consumes a lot of the physical
memory whereas this work station may be idle and therefore
all of this memory is not being utilized at
this point for running anything useful because no applications are
running on these nodes. So this opens up a new
line of thought. Given that all these nodes are connected
on a local area network and some nodes may be busy while other nodes may be
idle. Is it possible if a particular node
experiences memory pressure, can we use the idle
cluster memory, and in particular, can we use
the cluster memory that's available for paging in
and out the working set of the processes on this node? Rather than going to the
disk, can we page in and out to the cluster memories that are idle at this point
of time? It turns out that with advances in local area networking gear, it's
already made possible for gigabit ethernet connectivity
to be available for desktops. And pretty soon,
10 gigabit links are going to be common
in connecting desktops to the local area network.
This makes sending a page to a remote memory
or fetching a page from a remote memory faster than
sending it to a local disk. Typically, the local
disk access speeds are in the order of 200 megabytes
per second in terms of transfer rate, but on
top of that, you have to add things like seek
latency and rotation latency for accessing the data that you
want from the disk. So all of this augers well
for saying that perhaps paging in and out through the local area network to peer
memories that are idle may be a good
solution when we have memory pressure being experienced
at any particular node in the cluster. So
the global memory system, or GMS for short,
uses cluster memory for paging across the network.
So in other words in normal memory management,
if virtual address to physical address translation fails then
the memory manager knows that it can find this
virtual address on the disk, meaning the page that
contains this virtual address on the disk, it pages
in that particular page from the disk. Now in
GMS, what we're going to do is, if there
is a page fault, that is, this translation, virtual
address to physical address, fails then that means that
the page is not in the physical memory of this
node. In that case GMS is going to say, well
it might be there in the cluster memory, in one
of the nodes of my peers, or it could be on
the disk if it is not in the cluster memory
of my peers. So that's the idea that GMS is
sort of integrating the cluster memory into this memory hierarchy.
Normally, when we think about memory hierarchy in a computer system,
we say there's a processor, there's the caches, and there's the
main memory, and then there is the virtual memory sitting on
the disk. But now in GMS, we're sort of extending that
by saying in addition to the normal memory hierarchy that exists
in any computer system, that is processor, caches and memory, there
is also the cluster memory. And only if it is not
in the cluster memory, we have to think of going to
the disk in order to get the page that we're looking for.
That's sort of the idea. So in other
words, GMS trades network communication for disk I/O. And
we are doing this only for reads, for
reading across a network. GMS does not get in
the way of writing to the disk, that is the disk always has copy of all the
pages. The only pages that can be in the
cluster memories are pages that have been paged out
that are not dirty. And if there are dirty
copies of pages, they are to be written onto the
disk just like it will happen in a regular
computer system. In other words, GMS does not add any
new causes for worrying about failures because even if
a node crashes all that you lose is clean copies
of pages belonging to a particular process that may have
been in the memory of this node. But those pages
are on the disk as well. So the disk always has all the copies of the pages.
It is just that the remote memories of
the cluster is serving as yet another level in
the memory hierarchy. So just to recap the
top level idea of GMS. Normally, in a computer
system if a process page faults that means
that the page it is looking for is not
in physical memory, it'll go to the disk to get it.
But in GMS, what we're going to do is if a process
page faults, we know that it is not in physical memory but
it could be in one of the peer memories as well. So
GMS is a way of locating the faulting page from one
of the peer memories, if it is in fact contained in one
of the peer memories. If not, it's going to be found on
the disk. So that's the idea behind that. So when the virtual
memory manager, the virtual memory manager that is part of
GMS, decides to evict a page from physical memory to
make room for the current working set of processes running
on this node, then what the virtual memory manager is going
to do is, instead of swapping it out to the
disk, it is going to go out on the network
and find a peer memory that's idle, and put that
page in the peer memory so that later on if that
page is needed, it can fetch it back from the peer and memory.
That's sort of the big picture of how the global memory system works.